[Music]
hello and welcome to marshall matters
with me winston marshall at the
spectator offices in london
today i'm joined by american writer
author and musician coleman hughes this
is a little bit different this episode
because
as well as coleman being a guest on
martial matters
this is also been recorded for his
podcast conversations with coleman so
this is a joint podcast coleman thank
you so much for having me on your show
and thank you so much for coming on to
mine
hey winston
it's great to be on your show and
welcome to my show thank you um yeah i'm
delighted to uh have you on i've
actually been a great admirer of yours
for quite some time and i think i told
you this
in person when we met in
new york earlier this year but
i first came across your writing uh i
think it was the coilette pieces you
wrote
uh in 2018
and uh they were
a voice
it was a voice when i was living in new
york at the time actually and and uh
at the time that everyone was talking
about uh it was
the race literature then was uh
uh writers like tanehasi coates and
patrice khan colors and i was reading
all of that and then i read your
um coilette pieces and a lot of
references to thomas allen a completely
different type of thinking
and then
to my surprise discovered that you were
a rapper and
a uh i shouldn't perhaps have been so uh
uh surprised as um uh you know uh you're
obviously a very talented guy but you
went to juilliard and you have this huge
musical uh background first and foremost
um i guess the surprise is that you're
such a good you're such an impressive
writer but also such an impressive uh
musician
um so uh
you know
i might be i might be inventing this
memory but around that time that you
would have discovered my colette pieces
i think i remember someone showing me a
picture of you with jordan peterson
and you at this point were known to the
world as the lead guitarist and
banjoist of mumford and sons and jordan
peterson was one of the few people that
really supported me and amplified my
early colette essays and was
possibly the reason even you were
reading them
so i could be inventing that memory but
i do have a faint glimmer of a memory of
of
oh this guitar player from mumford and
sons took a picture with jordan peterson
yeah that that's right yeah um he came
to our studio in
mid uh 2018 we were making uh the record
delta and we had lots of people in and
he was
um
certainly someone that i discovered him
through i think a sam harris podcast he
did and
then he had this
there was one interview he did with joe
rogan where he
reconciled science and religion and
metaphysic in a way that i'd
never
really heard before and it and it and it
really blew my mind and actually making
that record he was
um
really influential uh particularly or
certainly on me and and
the and and
pushed me and you know he talks a lot
about um sort of the the line between
order and chaos and from a musical point
of view there's there's so much
to that in in that you and not just in
the music itself and that you need to
leap into chaos um to find them to find
the magic but also in the songwriting
process you need to put yourself in in
in that place that is chaotic to uh you
know
even if it's internal chaos to to really
um
uh
say the most important things or write
the most important songs to you i know
that sounds a bit grandiose but it
certainly had a a big uh he had his work
had a big influence on me and and he
wasn't a a political influence for me it
was it was more philosophical and
yeah in that sense
did you happen to see the beatles
documentary
the get back well i haven't seen hours
of
yeah yeah the eight hours of rehearsal
footage
no
the peter jackson
yeah yeah
i mean it's pretty interesting from from
a songwriting perspective and also
interpersonal dynamics of a band i'm
curious what you would think as someone
that was in
an extremely productive touring famous
band for what 10 years
14 yeah
14 years
what you would have i mean you should
just watch it because
there's clearly just a love affair
between paul and john the whole time
and a kind of
sidelining and condescension towards
george harrison
but
the the net result of whatever their
thing is
just works out in the end
and
it was very cool to get an inside look
at a situation that that
you know you've probably been in a lot
sort of composing with a band
there's one aspect
of uh
being being in a band that
is is both difficult but i think
also um
leads to a great quality of work is a
sort of sense of competitiveness or
a sense of trying to impress each other
um and if someone brings in a song you
want to do a better song and and i can
imagine that being
in like in football in terms having like
a messi and a renata at the same time i
imagine they're perfectly friendly but
they're they want to
the the success of the others wants them
makes them want to up their game and
compete with them so i i i difficult as
that often is in the band i think it
makes for
uh greater
output uh
in the in the long run
i think for my audience
we should
give a little history of
your involvement with mumford and sons
and the reasons you chose to left to
leave the band
in uh was it 2021
that's right so uh
in march
2021 uh which was in the middle of
lockdown
i don't know what 12.
um
i tweeted about a book now i'd been
tweeting about books throughout my
uh
lockdown it was one of the themes of my
social media and the book i tweeted
about was andy knows unmasked which is a
documentation of far-left extremism
in the states and
somehow and i do sort of feel like it
was an act of god it completely blew up
and before
and just for people just for people
recollection when you talk about
far-left extremism we're talking a lot
about places like portland
and seattle portland where andy noah has
spent a lot of time and actually been
assaulted by
antifa
protesters who he is infamous to and and
hated by
um so go ahead
yeah so and and as you can be more
specific it's it's not antifa in history
it's not antifa in 1930s london it's not
antifa in uh
1960s italy it's antifa specific today
in america and it's those it's portland
and i it covers the um blm riots uh
through 2020
and
that book uh then
that tweet rather
uh
kind of miraculously
blew up
um
uh it was a congratulate congratulatory
tweet because he just had just been
published and i didn't have that many
followers
and it blew up and um before long it was
uh a kind of segment on tucker carlson
and the view and
um
i then put out an apology for um
uh putting out the
the for the
people who had been offended by the
tweet
and after
a few months of careful reflection uh i
decided that
uh
i couldn't uh i i hadn't anything to
apologize for um except for uh
pulling the rest of the band into
this hot button issue because
antifa and far left extremism
like uh trans stuff like abortion stuff
is a very divisive
issue and uh i decided i wanna just read
the i wanna read the tweet for people
too so they have context
congratulations at mr andy know
finally had the time to read your
important book you're a brave man
and this is in a context where andy had
been very publicly
beaten
with scars all over his face
and i believe had to go to the hospital
as a result of a beating that was
started by antifa
so
to say he is brave is to say he's a
journalist going into the line of fire
of
violent people who hate him and have
assaulted beaten him to a pulp before
well quite and and in the period after
my apology he and this i think was in
may
april or may
yeah april or may 2021
he was beaten again and when that uh he
was in portland and there's and there's
video footage of that beating and when
when i saw that i i decided i really i
was right he was a brave guy in in
reporting on that stuff
um there's a lot of um
accusations thrown at him that he's far
right i couldn't find any actual
evidence of that
and
um
so i came to the conclusion that for me
to stand by my apology would be to stand
by a lie and
uh i didn't want to be part of that lie
but at the same time i didn't feel like
it was fair on
the band for them to suffer and they
would have suffered for example
i was due to dj
festival and i'd been pulled from that
festival because someone else on the
bill that they'd hoped to book had
publicly criticized me and called me a
fascist
and
radio stations
threatened to
pull the band so there were real-life
repercussions for that opinion
and uh
so
i came to pollution i couldn't
stand by my apology but at the same time
uh it wasn't fair on the rest of the
band for them to suffer
and uh so my decision was to leave the
band and
stand by my convictions my earlier
convictions
actually
what's curious for me about the story is
um
this ties in with your song blasphemy
because in your song blasphemy um
there's two parts to that
uh firstly it's uh that you have an
opinions that you have suffered for um
amongst your peers uh i think one of the
lines is you you got booted from an
event or um you lost friends for having
certain opinions that's not that's not
exactly the the line but it's something
like that right
and um and then
it the second half of the song is the
taboo opinion that you
i suppose the hill that you died on
which was reparations or rather being
against
uh reparations being played paid
in america to um the descendants of uh
those who uh
suffered under the slave trade
under slavery in america rather so for
for me it's curious
you're curious to me because that's uh
very similar or certainly a lot of
echoes of my my experience and and i
suppose
i've got two questions for you and that
is it's the issues of
reparations but then also the real life
experience
of um being uh
ostracized for having the wrong opinion
yes so
i guess take it take it in reverse order
my experience was was definitely
different than yours because you were in
a famous band
i guess there's there's sort of three
levels of cancellation there's
me having been a normal person
and getting heat online for an opinion
that people don't like and and that can
be difficult and you it could even come
with security issues people making death
threats and so forth
then there's to be in in your range of
fame that you were in
where you're really
that stratum is the red meat of
cancellation because
you're famous enough to really have a
name and for for people to pay attention
to the fact that you've
done a tweet
but you're not kanye famous where you're
uncancelable and
you have total [ __ ] you money and [ __ ]
you fame or when kanye says you know
agree with it or not when he says
cancelable stuff
you can you can complain but he's still
kanye he's still going to drop an album
next month and everyone's going to
listen to it
so you were in this in between zone um
so i i think that's probably the worst
place to be
in terms of
the ability to express opinions about
difficult sub subjects or controversial
subjects you know what's what's
interesting to me is
you know reparations is
very polarizing
in america race issues are highly
polarizing in general
so i really i stepped into an issue that
i felt strongly about but that i knew
i had every reason to expect
based on my knowledge of american
culture am i having lived here my whole
life that the people who hated my
opinion were going to deeply hate it so
in that sense
it's always shocking to get that level
of hate for the first time i think for a
human being we're we're social creatures
and you never quite know what it's like
until you experience it i think
but
i did sort of know that i was stepping
on the land mine and was choosing to do
so because i felt very strongly about
the issue can we talk about the issue of
reparations just sure yeah yeah for
my for my audience so you not only did
you write various articles and i should
say in in this song blasphemy it might
be the only song
certainly the only rap song ever that
actually quotes the spec or cites the
spectator which seeing as i'm in the
spectator building right now i feel like
i ordered
where does it cite the spectator
well in the introduction of the song
there's a narrator saying he's written
for coolett and the spectator oh that's
right that's right that is right i can't
imagine um there's another uh
reference to the spectator so prominent
in pop culture um
but uh so taking uh reparations as a as
an issue not only were you writing uh in
in these um
magazines and papers but you were uh you
also went to the united states house
judiciary in june 2019 to argue bill h.r
40
uh to argue against
uh
reparations so maybe for
my listeners
what's what's the story in america over
reparations what's the debate and uh
and since 2019 where uh how things
developed
so my position
it's it's not exactly right to say it
was against reparations
full stop because
i believe in paying reparations to
living victims of any government
sponsored atrocity right living victims
of the holocaust
many got reparations i support that
um
you know so my position was actually
that
living victims of segregation and the
jim crow system in the south
which we all now view as one of the
great moral stains of our history
someone like my grandparents for
instance grew up under segregation in dc
it would make perfect sense to pay them
reparations for having grown up
in an apartheid system that we that we
now look back on with horror
to give someone like me reparations
for being
six generations removed from slaves
that makes no sense
and there's no precedent for that in
the history of reparations
like once you once you miss the victims
themselves or their children
i'm i'm unaware of
any serious precedent
much less a pattern of states
finding the
sixth great
grandchild of someone
um
and
cutting them a check in order to atone
for the suffering
visited upon their great great great
grandparent and the truth is i think i
mean the taboo truth is that the link
between
something awful that happens to me
and that being
that
vibration being felt by my great great
great great great grandson
that link is not at all clear
i mean causation and and
the way
people's lives
change in a single generation i mean
there's like there's no reason to
believe actually that i am materially
harmed there's no way to know i would
say that i'm materially harmed by the
fact that my great great great great
great great grand
uh parents were slaves and that's in no
way to minimize the enormal an enormous
moral horror of slavery
it's it's just to say
i don't think that you know most black
americans are you know under the age of
40
under the age of 35 even
so
um that's the that's the case i was
really arguing against and
i guess
going go ahead what's the what's the if
you were to strongman the
position for reparations
how would you articulate that
okay well the the
if i were to steal man the position in
favor of reparations i would say
well in the first place we've paid
reparations many times before to many
other groups japanese americans
obviously holocaust survivors
and
the
the
this
basically the the
the sum of crimes against black
americans from slavery and jim crow have
created a circumstance where black
americans on the whole are less wealthy
than they would have been
had they not
experienced those
government sponsored
crimes essentially
so
it is up to the government
to restore black americans to where they
would be
but for
slavery
but for
jim crow and
reparations is the way
to do that
so actually
uh where this
where you would probably it sounds like
you'd agree is that
there are communities in america who are
the descendants of slaves who remain and
those communities remain poor
communities uh who uh
and that
uh
where they are economically is
partly because of that their history and
so that's a problem that america needs
to deal with generally speaking and
you're you would i imagine you would
agree that yes
whoever it is who's suffering left
behind there should be perhaps or maybe
you wouldn't but maybe there should be
government action but it shouldn't be in
the form of reparations
so
i actually would not agree with the
first statement
so i i
the problem of intergenerational poverty
in america i view as a very complicated
and independent problem i don't think
that you can say
slavery and jim crow are the reason
why there are
you know
x percent
maybe 20 percent
uh or whatever the poverty rate is
currently in in the black community that
that's why it is you know everyone who's
every black person who's poor is poor
because of slavery and jim crow i mean i
i do not believe that at all i think
um every single human being every single
american has a story of
why
they're situated where they are situated
that has a lot to do with
themselves and their parents
has a lot to do with a lot to do with
the hands that their their parents were
dealt
but every story i mean just think of any
friend that you have
who is who has a rags to riches story or
or something like the opposite of kind
of backsliding into the middle class
story
and how complicated any given one of
those stories is
not even a single one of those stories
can be reduced to
a single historical event from the 20th
century much less than 19th and 18th
centuries
so to say that
black people in america poor black
people in the hood in america today are
there because of slavery and jim crow
that is a fashionable but completely
simplistic sorry that's not my that's
not what i'm proposing though i i i more
i'm saying that it's one of the reasons
might be
that historically they come from from
that
horrible background that
not i'm not saying it's the only reason
but it might be one of the
one of let's say 100 reasons why
oh sure yeah no i mean
totally i would totally grant that
yeah i mean i i
uh
sort of with you my grandmother was a
holocaust survivor and the idea that i
would get
reparations
for
what her family and went through see it
would
it doesn't seem quite right to me but i
i agree with you and uh in that
i think it was in the early 50s that
germany paid israel
uh reparations and actually only last
year uh i think it was in march 2001 the
the
iraqi government uh in initiated the
yazidi survivor law where um
female and children survivors of the
isis atrocities in northern ark were
iraq were paid reparations uh or are
being paid reparations as a framework
for them to be paid reparations for the
suffering but that ties in with your
argument very much that they are
the direct sufferers of
you know they are the victims themselves
rather than the progeny of them
yeah and an
analogy i've made i mean as was true for
the japanese americans who were interned
in world war ii
i would add um
i
i've made an analogy before which is
that
when you meet someone who's
say their parents had a really hard life
their parents were from poverty and
struggle
but they themselves grew up with
privilege
there are people in that position that
sometimes try to assume
the
the struggle of their parents as their
own identity
right like sort of try to claim the
the street cred of their parents when in
fact they as an individual don't really
have any
and i i
this has always come across as a kind of
phony and a little bit insincere
thing to do i think most people sort of
see through that
kind of act
as as not the most honest way to have
your identity the honest ways to say
well i grew up with a lot of privilege
my parents didn't just fully represent
that reality rather than try to assume
right
basically what we are encouraging all of
black america to do with this
reparations angle
is to do that whole phony thing on mass
to assume the
suffering
of people that were actually slaves
people that actually did suffer
and take on that mantle as if we
ourselves suffered it
which is a pathological thing to
encourage people to do
well this obviously
is an idea that
has a real stronghold in your peers if
you felt so compelled to write the song
blasphemy and presumably this is the
blasphemy you're you're talking about
and
it's an idea that's that's so strongly
held that you were ostracized from your
friend group or is that is that right to
believe the lyrics
over the years in new york i i've
developed friend groups that are
from very different walks of life
so the the friend group that ostracized
me was
um
the
brooklyn
underground hip-hop community
which was
mostly black
um many of which came from poverty
um but beyond either of those
the the
crucial variable is that they were
basically the
their only concept of politics was
pro-black politics
and
so they saw me as going against
pro-black politics and that's
extremely taboo in that circle
what i was saying may have been a
controversial take in my other circles
but it wasn't
necessarily a cancelable
offense
um
with most of my friends
so is that brooklyn hip-hop scene a
politicized
scene is is oh yeah yeah yeah for sure
and so what does that the the sort of
the pro-black politics that you
described what what is that
what's the how would you describe it
it's
i would say it is roughly the the
political valence of black lives matter
i'm not sure that they necessarily would
like
the black lives matter global network
but it's it's pretty much
like graft your stereotype of the of the
politics of blm
of a
strong blm supporter
that's kind of the
center of the spectrum of that scene
right and so have you uh then
now making your music under uh cold man
have you have you
had any other pushback or have you found
a new community
uh in which to create with or or are you
sort of creating
a lot alone from that
how is how is it now working in the
music industry
um seeing as you're so publicly against
the the tide politically
yeah so i mean i make all my rap music
alone although i always have
what i used to do with on the scene is
kind of do shows together with other
people
um but i've always
by personality like to work alone so
that
it hasn't been much of a sacrifice in
terms of
sort of recording with other people
because that's not ever something i
i did it sometimes but but not very
often
um
but yeah not having access to
to people that used to be my friends
that i used to do shows with
um has been annoying but yeah you know
i've like i said i've i've
i've had a lot of friends in a lot of
different walks of life from
the jazz world
to
even the non-jazz world classical and
rock musicians
to um
you know as a writer i've met a lot of
people that have become my good friends
and so
i have
i had a lot of people
to
fall back on when i lost certain friends
i wasn't
feeling lonely
um
or if i was i had the capacity and
resources to
to
solve that by hanging out with other
people if i wanted to
okay so actually it hasn't
it hasn't impeded you you're making
music and and
uh it's just not going it's you found a
new sort of new avenue for it and you a
new way yes that's right yep yep i found
a new avenue
okay well that's that's
um that's certainly encouraging um uh
what one thing that i i thought but i'm
sorry i will say i will say i've had to
in many ways i've had to create that
avenue for myself
whereas before i could walk down avenues
that already existed
you know i've had to really put my
shoulder to to the
wheel and
build my own
musical platform build my own artist
identity
you've had to do more of the heavy
lifting
whereas normally you would be able to
sort of outsource that stuff or rely on
on other labels you've done it yourself
well
let me formulate it actually
more in what i'm trying to say is that
because i testified before congress
against reparations
when i'm as a rapper now talking to
publicists or
and i know you've had you know your
dealings with publicists
but you know all the intermediaries in
the music industry that you need
to deal with in order to be an artist
i have to do
you know 10 layers of damage control to
get them to talk to me because they can
google me and see that i've had these
cancelled opinions right
so
is that impossible no it's it's totally
possible
but it just it just means there's that
many more layers of resistance between
me and anything i want to do in the
mainstream music industry
and i've still done it but
behind the scenes there's been
like the cost in my time and effort and
my my manager's time and effort
in busting through those walls has been
immense
yeah i i
i thought about that a lot because i've
had a similar experience in that
even if the music industry is very small
there's and and pretty much everyone
knows each other and even if even the
people that i know are sympathetic or or
agree with me uh
on certain
things
they're almost all
all of them are at the mercy of their
clients so for example if you had
um
a publicist or a manager and then you
went on their roster
they might be fine with it they might
not have a personal problem with your
opinions and be happy to take you on but
uh
in hiring other clients or their
existing clients might see you on the
roster
and be oh why is that person on the
roster they they're problematic they're
controversial i can't work with you and
even if they don't do that the fear that
they might do that
will will be a wall
for people to work with let's say you
and me i imagine that's a look that's
one of my theories i think
no i think that makes a lot of sense and
um
well this is something i wanted to ask
you
which is i've noticed that
sometimes the fear of cancellation is
outsized
to the reality and that's
that's actually
a feature not a bug that's how it works
and i it's another analogy i've used
before
i just re-watched the pirates of the
caribbean movies this weekend because of
johnny depp
being so
in the media
there's a scene in the first movie at
the beginning where johnny depp pulls
into
this port
and there's three corpses rotting
corpses of pirates
hung there by the british as a warning
to the rest and he kind of takes his hat
off to his fellow pirates like
and
you know the point of hanging hanging
those corpses there is not that
most pirates get caught or should really
fear getting caught the truth is the
vast majority of them do not get caught
the point of hanging the minority that
do get caught in a very visible location
is to create an outsized sense of risk
so that you feel you're much more likely
to
prefer these things these things
to happen to you
and that creates
that's supposed to act as a widespread
deterrent right
so
that basically is how this works it's
it's like
is the person that manages you really
going to lose business
well
in in most cases maybe not
but just the small visible
examples of people getting cancelled
are like um they act like rotting
corpses for the rest of the world to see
and to run from
even if the likelihood of it happening
is is quite low
i think that's a superb analogy and i
think you're absolutely
right and i think that the people who
are hanging the corpses
realize how effective it is and that's
why they're
being so successful now in in in various
ideologies they know that they can scare
people um uh in in you know in in having
these scalps they know that how
effective it will be
and um and but when the but the even
when they're not necessarily there's not
that many of them behaving that way
mm-hmm
yeah
which
right which leads me to my other
question for you which is um
so as i was saying reparations that's an
issue i knew i was stepping into
that had a long history of being
controversial
um but
merely merely opposing
current american antifa
i mean that that is somewhat
controversial like on a university
campus
but
you know in the wider society
looking at what the crazy people in
portland do today
and post videos about doing
beating up journalists
like
this this stuff
they seem crazy they look crazy doing it
we're you know we're not talking about
the wider black lives matter protests
necessarily we're really talking about
the the hardcore antifa guys that
identify as as antifa
merely
retweeting a book
congratulating an author that's been
beaten up by them and is writing writing
a book against
their practices and goals
it seems like such a
tame thing to do
and i guess my question is
what would have happened
if your bandmates had said
[ __ ] the mob
all you did was tweet about a book that
we actually deep down we all know we
agree with we kind of all know
maybe not all of us but the vast
majority of reasonable people do not
agree with the folks that start burning
buildings that start throwing molotov
cocktails we run the other way we stay
inside we disagree with them by the very
fact of our behavior in fact
um
so what if they had just said you know
what [ __ ] the mob what you did we're in
a crazy moment we're just going to
hunker down we're not going to apologize
we're going to let it blow over
and i think that the fans will see that
you're not some fascist
um maybe a couple fans will leave but i
think our fan base understands who we
are
what do you think would have happened if
they had said that do you think mumford
and sons would still be touring like you
know your album records would still be
selling et cetera
i think that's a really good question
that should be asked to them i think
that's a question for them not for me
um but i what i do think um uh
uh
how well i do think that the the picture
painted
by that question
is that yes okay why do society agrees
that it's bad to throw to try and burn
down federal buildings
but the um the the strength the
the
the
people who are pro-antifa
um or let's say um pro
the extreme progressives or no i'll
phrase it differently
i think that the progressive
um
uh
worldview and um
politics uh or or people with those
politics have real control over the
culture in the way that
um
uh
that there is not an opposition uh with
it within
the culture so i i think that when you
look at
um the institutions
of uh let's say the music industry or
hollywood
they are
captured by
these progressives and and i'd say
extreme progressives in a way that there
is a fear to um be to speak out which i
don't think represents the whole country
sorry that wasn't a very clear answer
but no no no no that makes sense
i mean my i the sense i've gotten from
talking to
people
in the tv industry for example
is that
most of them you know the the attitude
the word for the attitude they have
towards the far left
is terror
that's it
like if you if you catch them in an
honest moment
over a beer where they have no reason to
lie to you they're comfortable
it's i'm terrified
of cancellation
especially if it almost doesn't matter
but especially if you're a straight
white male
it's just you know every decision i make
whether it's to green light a tv show to
to sign an artist
is a decision that could lead to my
cancellation and that can't those
cancellations only seem to come from
from one direction at least for the
hollywood folks very few of them are
being you know you know
canceled for platforming communists or
something like that or so certainly no
one's being troubled cancer
platforming uh
um communist although as a side note i
would say that that i've certainly seen
conservatives and right wingers
happy to cancel almost as readily as
progressives
and i saw this particularly when i
apologized for reading that book
then a whole uh
horde of
right wing is saying now i hope you get
cancelled so actually i do think that
the conservative or a vast amount of
large groups of conservatives are not
anti-cancer culture they're just anti
themselves or the people who agree of
them being cancelled but uh yes
they are they're
that's a really important distinction to
me they're not anti-cancer culture and
in principle many of them
the nasty online ones
um especially
they don't like the fact that the
culture is more controlled by the left
and and therefore
they're not really able to cancel people
to the extent the left is able to cancel
people because they control
most of the culturally powerful
institutions
yeah
but then as to examples of people let's
say you mentioned people working in tv
who are nervous to green light uh
whatever show it is or um i think that
they are right to be scared now the
difference in my position is that
you know
i've made money and i'm a big boy i can
i'll be all right but
if you uh don't have a huge amount of
savings and you've got a mortgage
and you've got to support a family the
idea of actually losing all that
and and the the world in which you
support
that that needs the income and and your
uh your job
it's not just losing a job you lose a
lot and so i totally understandable why
those such people would be
um
nervous
or scared totally yeah i i never
i never want to imply or certainly ever
call anyone a coward for not speaking
out because
everyone is differently placed to deal
with the consequences of speaking out
you might have family
you might have no safety net
um
and so
you know a lot of people that want to
speak out against
uh
an absurd restriction on common sense
arguments and ideas
will end up listening to podcasts like
mine or yours
and supporting them as a way of
doing their part when they can't
actually
afford to
say what they think at their job or
or worse among their friends
that's that's the scariest part is
if you can't
say what your thoughts are around the
people
that you're choosing to be around
because you like each other so much
that's what friends are
it's like if you can't
talk to them then
we're sort of doomed
and and
i remember as well
uh issuing my apology a lot of uh
political pundits saying never apologize
you shouldn't have apologized and i got
a bit annoyed at that because
i wanted to say you don't [ __ ] know
what pressure i'm under here
and and so and i've recently seen uh
interestingly there's a an english
singer called sam fender who's in his
mid-20s
and he's from newcastle he's a young
geordie lads he's
he's playing arenas here he makes great
music it's kind of springsteenie
and last week he was photographed in the
pub with johnny depp and jeff beck in
newcastle because uh
johnny depp's uh on a tour of the uk as
i guess a celebration tour um and um
he posted on instagram uh with a couple
of heroes in the pub something like that
and a couple of days later
issued an apology i'm so sorry for
calling him a hero essentially throwing
uh debt under the bus
and
um now
although i think
that's a bit uh it strikes me as a a bit
unfair on death in that scenario at the
same time i don't know what pressure
fender is under um behind the scenes and
so i i
you know wouldn't criticize him
necessarily or you know i'm gonna i
accept the fact that i don't know the
whole story
um
but
we're talking about this apologizing
thing yeah i've encountered this
never apologize idea mostly from the
right
which um
you know i i also think it's wrong i
think
the right attitude is to apologize if
and only if you actually feel
if and only if your considered self
thinks you did something wrong
like the the part of yourself that
reflects and has time to think if that
part of you believes you've done
something wrong
that is
exactly when you should apologize if you
have the freedom to act in a principled
way
if you're thinking about
you know your business tanking and you
just have to make practical calculations
that's another
matter
but
you should apologize when you mean it
and if you believe you did nothing wrong
then you should not apologize
the the only
counter to that and it's a small it's a
small nuance is that if you're at a
dinner table say
and you say something that you don't
think is offensive but you look around
and you see
someone aghast and you and you know that
they're offended you might say oh i'm so
sorry have i offended you
tell me you know what what have i said
you know you you would you would start
by apologizing i'm so sorry i didn't
mean to finish
what's offensive
so there is um unfortunately when you
get into sort of tweeting things where
tweeting you might it might be a similar
response to that oh i'm sorry i didn't
say what's the
um
what's the what's the problem but
actually when you tweet something you're
actually making a public statement so
it's kind of a
twitter maybe deceives you into thinking
you're just chatting but actually you're
making public statements um but that
that's a specific you know a little a
little nuance to it a little yeah no i
agree with that i think you know i never
i've been in this situation a few times
too where i just say something and i can
see
someone is just
grievously offended by by what i've just
said suddenly and i
you know i'm a pretty
i'm not a very confrontational person in
those situations like i don't
i feel no need to get to the bottom of
it
at dinner
i'm happy to move on and talk about the
weather
so
saying i'm sorry in that situation is
a way of signaling that i'm
i'm happy to let it go if this is an
emotional topic for you i've got no idea
what baggage you bring to the issue and
i respect that and like let's you know
let's talk about the latest episode of
how i met your mother or whatever
um so but but that's actually not the
same meaning as i apologize for
because
a real apology
to me it only counts if you describe
exactly why you were wrong
it's like this is what i did that was
wrong and i did it because of this
shitty selfish reason and there was no
excuse for it that that's really that's
a full apologies like a description of
what you did wrong why why you did it
and why
why there's no excuse for it and why
it's nobody's fault but your own
that's really
a full full-throated apology a quick i'm
sorry can just be a way of signaling
that i'm happy to move on to a more
congenial topic yeah
no i agree with that
um one uh
thing that i think makes you stand out
uh particularly amongst the the
counter-culture uh so to speak
is that or
it seems to me that the counter-culture
doesn't have much of a culture and and
it's rather just a lot of criticisms
of um the excesses of progressive
thought and
um the
progressive
culture
as we've discussed already dominates in
hollywood music perhaps tv
you know netflix well actually netflix
did uh
not kowtow to the anti-chappelle or
gervais um critics so so maybe it's not
so bad there anymore but
um it seems to me
and i was just read douglas murray's
latest books which actually curiously
relates to your song blasphemy not only
because it has a chapter on uh
reparations or against reparations but
uh you you uh he also talks about tiny
timper i think is is the name of the the
white guy in america who was killed in a
similar way to george floyd and and you
referred to him in in blasphemy but um
uh the the
thing about douglas's book is that
he
criticizes uh progressives but and his
answer is it's which he touches on a
little bit is to celebrate the great
things about the west the western canon
and western literature and art and
architecture but it's only a small a
small
part of the book and
where you're different is that you are
actually creating a culture
you are
making music and you're not just writing
and criticizing you're actually offering
something new and uh
struck me there's a guy called andrew
doyle i'm not sure if you're familiar
with this um guy but i yeah
he's a funny guy that does the
parody character right
he's the man behind titiano mcgrath um
which is
spoof
you've met him and he um
he
is a very prolific writer he's written a
book on free speech i interviewed him on
this podcast on my podcast and um
he has a show called free speech nation
he writes regularly
and
i bumped into him the other day
curiously on holiday and
i learned that he was a playwright first
and foremost and he asked me the
question well firstly i was like how did
i not know he was a playwright and
because he's so consumed by
um
you know criticizing uh or or
you know commentating on on on the
culture wars or or politics
and um uh it never occurred to me that
he was i never knew that he was he was a
playwright and he asked me that you know
winston you're doing
you you said something like you're you
know you're commentating on this stuff
you're writing you're criticizing
policies but what are you making and
what
what do you really want to be doing and
it's a
it's a great question because there's so
much energy going into criticizing um
progressive excesses let's say or or the
other side
um but the counter culture doesn't seem
to have much of a substantial culture
and yet you
you are one of the few people actually
putting the effort into creating one
yeah i remember one time i was at a
museum many years ago
reading the descriptions of every piece
of artwork and these were new
commissioned pieces of art at some
museum in new york
and
almost every description of the new
piece
would
include the language and philosophy of
intersectional feminism in some way
the philosophy of intersectionality or
critical race theory
and words like anti-capitalists would
get thrown around
uh in other words the justification for
the art there's a philosophy behind that
art and it was all the same philosophy
it was all one i was familiar with
from the halls of columbia university in
barnard
where i was a
student and
i thought to myself well isn't it
strange that all of the art in this
museum
has the same philosophy it's like
shouldn't you expect that there would
just be one painting that was a pro
capitalist painting or something like
that like even one artist that
just kind of had the opposite philosophy
and
did a doodle at least
and um
you know i started thinking about that
and
and this gets to exactly what you're
talking about
the question is sort of where is the
conservative art
where is the conservative music
um
there's actually a hilarious clip from
family guy
where
it's it's almost like it's not quite a
cutaway but it's sort of like peter
griffin talks to the camera
about how you know why every hollywood
movie has a sort of vaguely liberal or
left-wing punch line
he's like something like how many movies
have been written about like the old guy
stuck in his ways that like gets his
mind opened
to
you know new people or new race it
becomes a little less racist or a little
less homophobic or whatever
it's like where are the where the
hollywood movies where the punchline of
the movie has a kind of
you know conservative lesson right a
nugget of wisdom that
a douglas murray or roger scrutin would
write about about saying you know
valuing traditions not throwing away
traditions too soon or
any of the other kind of nuggets of
wisdom that that conservatives
tend to focus on
um
he's like can you name a single movie
that that has that
moral of the story i think the truth is
you actually can
name movies
like that but
it was an interesting comment on
the
perception of a political skew to the
whole art and culture
um world
the to me
um
you know i i don't exactly know about
this because it seems to me that
there is a good deal of
non-progressive art
i mean
so let's like let's
the the immediate thing that comes to
mind is that if you look at
the big comedy
the biggest comedians today in american
britain are gervais rogan and chappelle
and the biggest shows are
i or two of the biggest shows are south
park and family guy now it's not to say
that any of those are conservative in
fact you can say definitely chappelle is
not conservative
but you might say but certainly
south park and family guy aren't
conservative either
sure but they're certainly they they
ridicule
um progressivism and so conservatives
would enjoy
and do enjoy those
shows and and and those um stand-ups so
it's it's weird to think of any art as
being conservative or or even
progressive
right
specifically although that does exist
and like there are bands that are
explicitly communist that have communist
messaging
and
so you can have
that does sort of exist but
lower down apart from apart from those
big stars there isn't a kind of
or if there is it's people are very
quiet about their politics if they're
also creating art
um
beneath that there's also those behemoth
artists yeah
and i think sometimes the contradictions
are so huge
and and in front of us that we never
talk about it so for example
progressives would see themselves as as
broadly supportive of hip-hop as a black
art form you know kendrick lamar got the
pulitzer prize
i think well deserved i think his new
album is genius and he he's incredible
but broadly speaking
there's nowhere you will find more
misogynistic lyrics than in hip-hop and
in mainstream hip-hop
and you know the objectification of
women and all the rest
but the same progressives that are
absolutely staunch
on the any anything relating to
respecting women
will never say a word you know almost
never never say a word about the the
just
like constant hoes of
[ __ ] hoe [ __ ]
in in you know every third rap song
and
uh you know i've always found that to be
kind of hilar hilarious i i always
thought it was really interesting to
watch
you know girls that went to barnard
and
you
you know used they pronouns
and um didn't
you know read one fake article
about the wage gap and couldn't stop
telling you about
about it but then would then go go to a
like a rap concert in new york and
listen to trippy red call her a [ __ ] all
night and be like this is great and
totally not a contradiction
there's a curiously in in hip-hop
culture
american hip-hop culture there's
uh there's a history of
celebrating rags to riches and
celebrating wealth and money and glamour
and you you know it doesn't take much to
think of a hip-hop video with a bouncing
car
and uh jewelry or bouncing ass
and so oddly though but those are cons
you know those are conservative ideas um
and you know about free market and
working and
working you know earning your money in
in a way that's a conservative opinion
that you don't hear rap songs about
steak and like let's have the state you
know do more this and let's have uh the
state you know control healthcare or
something like that i'm not sure i can
think of them as quickly
um
so in a sense you could say hip-hop has
a
kind of conservative
uh tradition to it
oh totally i mean i would you and i
wouldn't be the first to make that point
that
where in american culture are you going
to find the most resounding
defense of owning a gun being ready to
use it making lots of money in a
capitalist system
and being kind of retrograde in your
attitude to women
not
from fox news from mainstream hip-hop
yeah um can i ask you about your um your
book uh i i understand that you're
writing and that
when we last spoke you told me that it's
called racialized um i'm not sure how
much you've gone public with it but we
can obviously cut this if you haven't if
it's not time to talk about it
yeah it may not be time to talk about
the title
you can talk about the the content i
guess because it the title is something
that can
be reworked and
negotiated
with the powers that be but
but yeah i mean basically i'm trying to
i'm trying to write a defense of the
concept of colorblindness
colorblindness is
a dirty word now if you
if you google color blindness
race
google those two words so that you don't
get articles about
you know like people that can't see
colors
literally you know black cones and rods
in their eyes
you'll get i mean at least i got in my
google filter
you know 10 straight articles on why
color blindness is the wrong approach to
race and
really the the people that advocated
that decades ago
were wrong-headed and naive and what we
have to do now is
really focus on seeing race
seeing
me as for instance a black person and
you as a white person
and
the way to a healthy equilibrium on race
is to
crank up the dial on our
racial identities and how much we care
about what race we are
um
and and not only that but
the idea is that's the only way to
sort of get to
get past jim crow and slavery and racial
discrimination it's like we we can't do
that if we're going to
ignore race that's the idea the
prevailing idea now
uh certainly in the elite
and that also comes with a whole package
of
race-based laws like
you know affirmative action and
covid racial preferences
and
and all the rest you know diversity and
inclusion
hiring
so i'm trying to write a book that
just makes the full case for
color blindness that we need a national
reset
on race
where we say look horrible things
have been done in the past nobody's
denying that
but the way to fix that is not to double
and triple down on uses of race
um in the other direction
right
that that's not
the way out an eye for an eye
as the saying goes makes the whole world
blind so i'm trying to argue that we
just need a national reset
where we
re-commit to the principle of
race is meaningless
like skin color is is an absurd
way to
an absurd variable to form your identity
around it's an absurd reason to ever
feel divided from anyone else
it's absolutely stupid and meaningless
and
all of the
the quotes and sentiments that have now
become cliche from martin luther king
and the civil rights movement
they are cliche precisely because they
are so true
and we risk
sort of repeating those mantras and
cliches to the point where we actually
don't hear them anymore
and don't
don't use them as our guiding lights in
our public policy and in our
relationships with other people
yeah i i it's so
palpable for any english person to go to
america uh and and it's always sort of
been like this even before the
escalation in in the in the
uh culture wars i guess uh from 2015 but
in in america it's
so
people are defined by their race even if
it's not
uh or or
um it's it's talked about so much more
than in britain where until recently
again and certainly since george floyd
uh before that race was
it wasn't such a
spoken about thing it and and and the
racialization of of britain is
or to see everything through the lens of
race has is seems so uh regressive and
it's been quite
shocking to to see us adopt those
uh that what i see as a kind of american
mindset okay it's like slightly irks me
um when people say that only because
especially people from european
countries where
you've had a history where
your ethnic groups and ethnic divisions
have been purposely bounded
by borders
and slaves and colonies were kept
overseas
you know for
where there was where in america
the challenge we faced was that when
slavery ended the slaves were living
right next to the masters
you know that was a challenge that was
never faced by european countries with
cut which kept their colonies hundreds
or thousands of miles away
and so
it's it was a different
challenge to begin with and it was you
know the difference in the american
identity is that it's not it was never
supposed to be an ethnic identity so are
you hopeful that
america can find
or or can can get to a place of color
blindness do you think it's possible in
a nation of so many different
groups of so many different religions
and uh different beliefs that they can
be united under those
those liberal enlightenment ideas on
which it was founded
so it will
never fully
win i i don't expect my principles to
ever fully win out
what i do think is possible is for us to
do much better than we've been doing
and
for a critical mass
among people with power
people in the elite
um who
let's face it are more the ones that are
going to be reading
reading
a book of this sort to begin with and
who who are more of the ones that are
creating this problem
like this this problem of
woke race obsession
is overwhelmingly an elite problem
mostly what working class people expect
when they come to america is
a
a facially
race neutral system in which they can
work their ass off
that that's what
people don't ex you know
asian americans aren't expecting to come
to a country where they're going to get
asian-american benefits right
they're expecting to come to a country
that
hopefully will not discriminate against
them or hold them down and will give
them a chance to come to to live the
american dream
and that that's been the expectation for
hundreds of years in this country is i'm
gonna go to a place where i won't be
persecuted that has a legal system in
place that will treat me as an
individual and i will be able to fight
my way in this in this
system right
um
but
but what what i would hope is that a
critical mass of
people in power will be able to
say no to race obsession
and to say yes to
enlightenment ideals
and procedural fairness and treating
people as an individual rather than a
member of their racial group
and the more people do that the more we
are
you know
steering
steering our ship through this storm
in a way that
will allow it to survive
um and and will minimize interracial
inter-ethnic conflict so i know so to
answer your question no we're never
gonna be perfect or anything close to it
but i view what i'm advocating for as
someone who's
akin to someone who's advocating for
peace rather than violence
right like
you never actually expect to zero out
the violence but at the very least you
wanna know that you're going in the
right direction right and what i fear
we've lost is that no one even talks
anymore about
the desire to be a colorblind nation
in the in the 70s and 80s and 90s
you had
people like thurgood marshall you even
had radicals like the black power
movement in the 60s
when they wrote their manifesto for the
movement they said
yeah eventually we would like to become
colorblind but
on the way there we're gonna have to do
a lot of racial reckoning and seeing
race right
now you don't even hear that you don't
even hear the first caveat where they
say eventually we want to be colorblind
it's only the second half which is we
want to see race forever and ever
so if i could even get more people to
admit that eventually we want to be
colorblind we want to
more and more push people away from
identifying strongly with a race of
human beings a subcategory of human
beings
then i will consider it a success
i fully support you in that
um coleman
thank you so much for uh speaking uh
with me and uh absolutely winston thank
you so much for coming on my show as
well
i i i i feel very honoured to be uh uh
speaking and on your show and um
i uh
uh hope we can speak again and
um absolutely
yeah um my my i'm gonna treat my
listeners to your song blasphemy um so
they can hear your artwork and your
music rather and um
uh
yeah it's been a pleasure
amazing but before you go can you tell
my podcast listeners how to listen to
your podcast
absolutely
so uh i
have a
podcast called marshallmatters here at
the spectator and you can listen on all
usual podcasts outlets and on youtube
where i interview people across the
creative industries to find out what
indeed is the state of the arts
awesome
thanks winston
thanks coleman
mr coleman hughes is a columnist for
quillette he's had pieces published in
the new york times the wall street
journal the national review the city
journal and the spectator he's studying
philosophy at columbia university and we
appreciate your attendance and you're
recognized for five minutes sir
back with the pen took a sabbatical at
it again look at my attitude after they
call me a time and ray call me a coonis
at 10 [ __ ] at 10. don't tell me who
to offend losing a few of my friends
yeah i've been booted from public events
and it was always something i sent cause
it was class for me never was like an
audacity point
[Music]
that all the [ __ ] is passing me
trust that you ain't seen the last of me
pray i don't end up like calvary's over
some blasphemy make it official charge
me for thinking and put me in prison
serving a sentence for sentences written
should have known better than having
opinions got about 100k in my minions i
could lose half and still fill up a
building with a few extra despair like
michelin let me stop there cause i know
what you thinking you just saying [ __ ]
for white people [ __ ] you ain't hanging
with the right people bro i bet they
keep you on a tight leash before they
bring you out so you can fight people
let me school you like boy q with the
bucket hat drop your [ __ ] uncle
ruckus act stop forgetting that you
[ __ ] black cause the pigs won't want
your hands up and the pistols at your
[ __ ] back
[Music]
[Music]
our hands up for these white coppers
your hands out for these coke dollars
and that ain't the half of it this [ __ ]
don't stay in the past does it we built
the nation from scratch honey and we
still acting the cash from it so get out
the way ain't trying to hear what they
pay you to say ain't nothing changed 10
to 1 wealth ratio yesterday it's the
same as today so
go ahead make a name for yourself do
what you got to do for the fame and the
wealth i say it backwards you were out
in the cell factors you ain't nothing
but a cracker is still
slavery slavery slavery
you dwell on the past but letting it go
that requires more bravery
and last time i checked they all in the
grave are they in mauritania
i pass on a check for my lowest fee
uncle sam couldn't pay for me huh
i feel with my heart but think with my
head mix up the parts and we all end up
dead race is a fake idea put it to bed
ain't no debate i said what i said my
name is my name
cole man i got love for the world and my
soul man i am black i am white i am all
man we are stuck in between like toe jam
i'm an american i'm the american i
really don't give a [ __ ] about the color
of keratin or who you ferret in i had a
greek is my therapist i made this beat
from a theremin that ain't the [ __ ] i
inherited from the culture that me and
my parents live and it's still gas like
serenity so i'm a little bit even killer
i okay
you heard i'm unapologetically from the
verb but like apostle paul i bring
i'm in the business of brute facts you
see i'm in the business of new
blasphemies i've taken bullets for two
magazines and back and you shout to me
like advocacy
chill chill chill chill he was
presumptive but he still has a right to
speak like i need your permission
all of you tripping i'll leave you
blinded by colorful vision all of the
stories you tell are too simple y'all
heard a floyd but y'all ain't heard a
temper
i don't fear getting shot by a cop i
feel my mind getting brainwashed by a
mob i feel right getting made from
couple wrongs i feel what i call truth
y'all gonna call blasphemy never was
lacking audacity point to a flaw in a
fallacy right on a different mentality
committing that blasphemy
that all the [ __ ] is passing me
trust that you ain't seen the last of me
pray i don't end up like calvary over
some blasphemy